well when you see a guy like khabib
nurmagomedov
just run through people in the UFC and
you know where that guys from you got to
go well how many more of those guys are
over there you know yeah the Dagestan
crew then that does upbeat - he's from
Dagestan isn't islam makhachev isn't he
from that that part of the world as well
yeah yeah that's where uh Keller's areas
boom boom boom boom boom that's it
yeah so I mean the top round right yeah
yeah yeah that's a warrior group of
people yeah yeah it's a lot of man Jerry
so I get to go there a lot I mean it's
really exciting I get to see a lot of
really cool still his Dagestan like okay
Dagestan was a blast
Dagestan was fun really yeah I went
there I you know was there with us who
was also at the show they brought over
Verdun and and those guys weren't
working for doing and Anderson Silva
those guys are watching fights you just
you know but I was working but yeah they
took us around they showed us a lot of
really cool stuff I went to like a you
know school were some kids wrestling
school okay like a lot of schools that
were athletic with an athletic
orientation and seeing these little kids
maybe put this little kid up on a bar
had him doing pull-ups man he was doing
pull-ups I mean this little kid little
bitty kid did I mean it must have been
at least 15 pull-ups and then I was like
I mean he's a little kid like something
like nine or something like that if I
went coach when the coach pulled him off
he was mad you could see these meds like
man I got more you know they're mean he
was mad like well there's show the
people what I could do but um and the
crowd they loved him ma so much they
were like it was like you know what it
was like it was like you were watch
those videos of like um the Beatles
you didn't even when all the people
going crazy but it's not teenage girls
it's like a bunch of hard little
wrestlers well just packs like yeah sure
they're from somewhere yeah 17 Wow so
it's that popular over there yeah
dancing now did you see the video of
those dudes when could be beat Conor and
they're shooting machine guns into the
air oh I didn't see that but I saw the
one of my friends from that area sent me
some pictures that she was out on the
street she sent some pictures uh
to
to my wife of the masu video of guys
like jet Ginga and horse racing had
horses their horses down yes in video
that was like o course racing and
shooting guns yeah there people were it
was like people were so excited about
that
that's some energy there yeah make you
imagine you're from a place that many
parts of the world never heard of mm-hmm
until now I don't know how much I've
thought about Dagestan before to be came
around and then now they have the not
just a world champion but a guy who
smashed the most famous fighter on the
planet right one of the most famous
fighters on the planet
it's like him and Floyd Mayweather
probably the two most famous fighters
yeah yeah yeah it could be just ran
through him so like he's a he's a huge
huge star over there
yeah no no yeah huge so there that uh ya
know it's it's a fun place to go matter
of fact I yeah I've got to see a lot of
cool stuff look at this Dagestan
explosive delight after khabib defeats
mcgregor they're all going crazy with
their hats on look at people on the
street cheering yeah wow yeah man
Conner's all the shit talk leading up to
that fight men to that backfire like on
some people it works and then some
people it's just it doesn't work at all
and it just makes him more relentless
when kabhi was hitting him going let's
talk now uh-huh let's talk now that's
account with him you know cuz he talks
the whole time right yeah from the
beginning the a he starts talking to be
does oh yeah he starts to talk really
what does he say well I didn't you hear
when used to fight in Johnson yeah give
up yeah yeah yeah you know I need that
title shot give up then he got him in
that horrific Kimora I was watching that
Comoros I talked to use a fucking tap
come on man
tap come on man oh just feeling
everything going pop snap oh they didn't
want to tap man is a tough guy yeah but
I you know that uh either the smack talk
I mean that's what Conner does yeah yeah
but this was a different level let's
talk mmm
is that come on let's talk now can we
hear it yeah as Michael Johnson yeah
uh-huh yeah
he sounds like you really cares about
into you know this I deserve it I have
to fight for the title you know this I
deserve it as he's beating him all right
yeah and he's talking to someone on the
side right